.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Schon als Kind haben sie
davon geträumt, Tierärzte zu werden.
Dafür müssen die Welschen
fürs Studium nach Bern.
An der Uni
sassen sie meist über den Büchern
und hatten kaum mit Tieren zu tun.
Jetzt müssen sie rund um die Uhr
für einen Einsatz bereit sein.
Der Berufsalltag ist hart:
24 Std., sieben Tage.
Darum wird jede und jeder Vierte
den Traumberuf wieder aufgeben.
Wir haben drei junge Tierärzte
begleitet:
Gwennaëlle
macht eine Spezialausbildung
für neuartige Haustiere und arbeitet
in einer Praxis im Kanton Waadt.
* Fröhliche Musik *
William macht ein Volontariat
in der Notfallstation
des Berner Tierspitals.
Im hochmodernen Spital
hat er mit kritischen und
teils hoffnungslosen Fällen zu tun.
Eléonore hat sich
den Kühen verschrieben
und arbeitet als Landtierärztin
in Porrentruy.
Es ist ein anstrengender Beruf
und man weiss im Voraus nie,
wie lange der Tag wird.
Und das sind sie:
unsere jungen Tierärzte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Es ist 8 Uhr morgens.
In der Tierpraxis Ajovet
in Porrentruy
klingelt schon das Telefon
und Eléonore fährt sofort los.
Gleich nach dem Studium
hat die damals 25-jährige Tierärztin
diese Stelle in Porrentruy gefunden
und ist jetzt seit einem Jahr im Jura
unterwegs - immer mit guter Laune.
Ich wollte
schon immer Tierärztin werden.
Als ich zum ersten Mal
einen Welpen hielt, sagte ich mir:
"Ich tue alles für dich,
dir wird nichts passieren."
So hat es begonnen.
Eléonore ist ein Stadtkind,
wollte aber schon immer auf dem Land
arbeiten, wo es viele Tiere hat.
Tiere sind für mich Wesen,
die sich gegen die Menschen
nicht wirklich wehren können.
Darum sehe ich es als meine Aufgabe,
sie zu beschützen.
Los geht's!
Eléonore ist bei Fernand
in Grandfontaine.
Wenn die Kühe kalben, ist der Bauer
Tag und Nacht auf den Beinen.
Wenn man Vieh hat,
ist man immer auf Trab
und ein wenig gestresst.
Ich gehe jeden Abend
in den Ställen nachschauen.
So kann ich nachher
viel besser schlafen.
Es liegt richtig.
Wir müssen aber nachhelfen.
Heute Morgen bringt Pivette
ein Kalb auf die Welt.
* Muhen *
Was ist es? Ein Weibchen?
Ja!
- Heute ist ein guter Tag.
Es ist immer schön zu sehen, wie
ein Jungtier zum ersten Mal atmet
und die Mutter es
vor uns beschützen will.
Wenn ein Kalb dank meiner Hilfe
lebendig zur Welt kommt,
vergesse ich alles, was diese Woche
schlecht gelaufen ist.
Solche Geburten
geben Eléonore auch die Gelegenheit,
sich bei den Bauern in der Region
zu bewähren.
Salut, Schätzchen.
Beim ersten Besuch
auf einem Bauernhof
kam ich mir manchmal
etwas verloren vor.
Aber nicht,
weil es eine Männerwelt ist -
es gibt ja immer mehr Bäuerinnen -,
sondern weil ich jung
und unerfahren war.
Ich habe einen sehr guten Einstieg
in den Beruf erlebt.
Ich habe von allen viel Vertrauen
und Verständnis erhalten.
Alle waren super zu mir.
8 Uhr würde passen.
Alles Gute, Nicole.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Bis Sonntag.
Du hast mich wieder Nicole genannt.
Ich habe manchmal
ein Durcheinander mit den Namen.
I c h bringe dich durcheinander.
Also ... Vielen Dank.
- Alles Gute. Gern geschehen.
Fernand hat Eléonore
zum ersten Mal geduzt.
D.h., er hat Vertrauen in sie.
Auch für William in Bern
beginnt ein neuer Tag.
Der junge Tierarzt
tritt voll in die Pedalen
und hat einen klaren Weg vor sich:
Er möchte Tierchirurg werden.
Mit vier Jahren wurde ich gefragt,
was ich werden will.
Schon damals sagte ich "Tierarzt",
nie etwas anderes.
Kaum hatte er das Diplom im Sack,
begann William ein Praktikum
im Tierspital in Bern.
Der Wechsel vom Studium in die Praxis
war brutal.
Es geht um lebendige Tiere,
um echte Fälle.
Das ist keine Übungssache mehr.
Man muss total konzentriert sein,
was manchmal schwierig ist,
und das den ganzen Tag.
William
trägt eine grosse Verantwortung.
Er arbeitet in der Notfallstation
des hochmodernen Berner Tierspitals,
das Tiere
aus der ganzen Schweiz aufnimmt.
Gerade wird ein schwer
verletzter Hund hereingefahren.
Es ist Falco,
ein siebenjähriger Border Collie
aus dem Kanton Neuenburg.
Gleich nach dem Unfall wurde er
von einem Tierarzt notversorgt.
Dieser Hund wurde mehrere Kilometer
von einem Auto mitgeschleift.
Er hat an allen vier Beinen
Verletzungen bis auf die Knochen.
Sie hat die Tiernarkose gewaschen
und gereinigt,
aber keine Röntgenbilder
oder sonst was gemacht.
* Piepen *
Sonst ist er stabil,
aber es ist wirklich sehr unschön.
Das steht alles im Bericht.
Er wurde schon vom Tierarzt
stabilisiert? - Ja, genau.
Der Besitzer
macht sich grosse Sorgen.
Als er heute Morgen arbeiten ging,
wusste er nicht,
dass sein Hund einen Unfall hatte.
Der Hund war vor dem Haus
an einem langen Seil angebunden.
Dann fuhr ein Lieferwagen vor und
das Seil verfing sich in den Rädern.
Als der Wagen weiterfuhr,
schleifte er den Hund mit,
etwa 1 km bis ins Dorf.
Er schleifte ihn
über 1 km neben sich her.
Da steht "Kilometer", ja.
- Oh Gott.
William ist schockiert: Einen
so schweren Fall hatte er noch nie.
Falcos Pfoten
sind bis auf die Knochen abgeschürft.
Also ...
So etwas sieht man nicht jeden Tag.
Wir müssen mit schweren Hautver-
letzungen und einem Bruch rechnen.
Auch die Lunge könnte verletzt sein,
oder er hat innere Verletzungen
in der Kopfregion.
Der Lieferwagen ist durch
Tempo-30- und -50-Zonen gefahren.
Er war bei 30, 50 km/h angebunden,
so etwas endet nie schön.
William versucht, ruhig zu bleiben,
aber die Zeit drängt.
Sind innere Organe verletzt,
kann der Hund jeden Moment sterben.
Ich möchte erst
den Blutdruck messen,
um zu schauen, ob er stabil ist.
Bist du ... Hat jemand ...
Im Moment ist Falco stabil.
William traut sich aber nicht alleine
an diese Verletzungen.
Er fragt seine Chefin um Rat.
Er hat offene Wunden
an allen vier Pfoten.
Ich habe sie nicht untersucht,
weil ...
Das musst du
unter Anästhesie machen.
Es ist besser, wenn wir alles
Es geht so schneller.
- Und es ist schmerzlos.
Der Hund hat Morphium erhalten,
sonst könnte er
die Schmerzen nicht aushalten.
Darum ist er auch so ruhig,
ganz anders als sonst.
* Piepen *
Er ist immer gut gelaunt.
Deshalb lasse ich auch immer
eine Leine im Milchkasten liegen.
Wird Falco je wieder gehen können?
Oder muss man ihm
die Pfoten amputieren?
William
hat noch eine schwierige Aufgabe:
das Gespräch mit dem Besitzer.
Herr Monneron.
Guten Tag miteinander.
Pownall. Guten Tag.
- Grüezi.
Können wir die Sache
im Sprechzimmer besprechen?
Ja, sicher.
- Bitte schön.
Die Besitzer merken sofort,
wenn man unsicher ist.
Dann reklamieren sie
und sagen dir direkt,
wenn etwas nicht geht
oder etwas nicht stimmt.
Ich habe eine erste Untersuchung
bei Falco gemacht.
Es wäre gut, wenn man jetzt die
Auswertung unter Anästhesie macht.
So könnten wir
das Ausmass des Schadens,
wenn ich das so sagen darf ...
- Er wurde mitgeschleift.
Voilà. Ich glaube,
er war zu wenig schnell
und ist mit dem Brustkorb
aufgekommen.
Die Verletzungen
reichen bis auf die Knochen.
Bei offenen Wunden ist das Risiko
einer Infektion gross.
Darum kann man
eine Amputation nicht ausschliessen.
Wenn es wirklich so ist, dass
die Verletzungen zu schwer sind ...
... dann müssen Sie ehrlich sein,
damit ich weiss, woran ich bin.
Ich muss wissen, woran ich bin.
Man soll offen und ehrlich
mit mir reden, mir alles sagen.
Für mich ist es sehr wichtig,
dass man offen mit mir redet.
Wenn es dem Hund zu schlecht geht,
sollte man sein Leben
nicht unnötig verlängern.
Das ist sicher hart, aber wenn man
die Entscheidung treffen muss ...
Okay, also ...
Ich rufe Sie gegen Abend an
und gebe Bescheid.
Ich hoffe, es kommt gut.
Wenn es dann besser ist,
ihn einzuschläfern,
weil er sonst
zu fest leiden würde -
das täte weh.
* Sanfte Musik *
Da er nicht mehr da ist,
ist es ganz still im Haus.
Keine Geräusche, kein Hund,
der gestreichelt werden will.
Es ist seltsam, so ein leeres Haus.
Falco kommt auf die Intensivstation,
bis er operiert wird.
Es ist noch frühmorgens.
Die Tierarztpraxis
in Rolle am Genfersee
hat eben erst geöffnet.
* Fröhliche, verspielte Musik *
Gwennaëlle ist 24
und hat nach dem Diplom hier
ihre erste Stelle gefunden.
Nein,
nicht an den Handschuhen nuckeln.
Anstatt in die Kaffeepause zu gehen,
gibt sie ihrem Marderbaby
die Flasche.
Sie liebt Tiere über alles.
Ich habe auch Nagetiere:
Degus, Hamster, Rennmäuse.
Und ich machte natürlich
sehr viel Dogsitting.
Du hattest doch schon.
Willst du noch mehr?
Es will noch mehr.
Schau, der Saugreflex!
Das Marderbaby wurde heute Morgen
in einem Stall gefunden
und gleich in die Praxis gebracht.
Jetzt muss man es
alle 2 Std. füttern.
Voilà, jetzt bist du sauber.
Noch eines.
Ich mag Wildtiere.
Deshalb interessieren mich
neue Haustierarten.
Es ist jedes Mal
eine Herausforderung zu sehen,
ob und wie man
so ein Tier retten kann.
Und das finde ich interessant.
Gwennaëlle will sich auf
neue Haustierarten spezialisieren.
Das sind v.a. Nagetiere,
Vögel, Fische und Reptilien.
Heute kommt sie auf ihre Kosten.
Ein Tierwärter
vom Tropiquarium in Servion
hat ein paar seiner Schützlinge
mitgebracht.
Er ist bissig.
Er beisst nicht nur,
er springt auch davon.
* Drolliger Hüpflaut *
Einen kurzen Moment.
Ganz ruhig. Ganz ruhig.
Thomas sorgt sich
um das Auge seines Basilisks.
Halt. Halt, halt.
Während der Fortpflanzung
geht es manchmal drunter und drüber.
Das Weibchen
wird dabei auch noch verletzt.
Manchmal haben sie
kleine Verletzungen oder Kratzer,
deren Ursprung man nicht kennt.
Er hat sich wahrscheinlich
an einem Ast oder Blatt gestossen.
Er sieht nicht mehr gut.
- Ja, das ist klar.
Zum Glück
ist es keine schlimme Verletzung.
Augentropfen sollten reichen.
Aber Gwennaëlle will ganz sicher sein
und fragt ihre Chefin,
ob sie was übersehen habe.
Ich brauchte eine Bestätigung,
denn anfangs ist es wichtig,
dass einem jemand sagt,
ob man richtig liegt oder nicht.
Auch wenn man richtig liegt,
will man eine Bestätigung.
Etwas mehr nach hinten.
Ich kann mich noch gut erinnern,
wie nervös ich am Anfang
bei einem Eingriff war.
Theoretisch wusste ich alles,
aber in der Praxis
ist alles etwas anders.
Man ist schnell einmal nervös,
wenn man ein richtiges Tier hält
und die Theorie anwenden soll.
Aber sie macht das gut.
Gwennaëlle
hat die richtige Diagnose gestellt.
Ein paar Augentropfen,
und das Auge ist bald wieder gesund.
Und jetzt
sind die Geckos an der Reihe.
Ich habe hier eine paar Namibgeckos,
die kleine Punkte haben.
Thomas hat auf den Geckos
kleine, braune Punkte entdeckt
und vermutet, dass es Läuse sind.
Er ist voll davon,
dort, wo die Haut hell ist.
Das ist superheikel.
Aber wie bringt man die Läuse
zur Untersuchung unters Mikroskop?
Ein erster Versuch mit Wattestäbchen.
* Fröhliche, verspielte Musik *
Das ist ... schwierig.
Das funktioniert gar nicht.
Zweiter Versuch: mit Klebeband.
* Fröhliche, verspielte Musik *
Jackpot!
Jetzt kann Gwennaëlle die Insekten
unter dem Mikroskop betrachten.
Ich glaube nicht.
Es sind kleine Milben
mit einem unaussprechlichen Namen.
Es sind Milben,
die man v.a. auf Schlangen findet.
In einem Zoo, wo viele Tiere
nahe beieinander leben,
können Parasiten
zu einem echten Problem werden.
Ich kann sie sehen.
- Ja, ist gut.
Aber ich sehe nicht,
wie viele Beine sie haben.
Ah ja.
Rechts sieht man drei.
Dann sind es Milben.
* Idyllische Musik *
Eléonore im Jura hat
das ganze Wochenende Pikettdienst.
Tierpraxis Ajovet.
Eléonore, guten Tag.
Ein Bauer sorgt sich um eine Kuh,
die am Kalben ist.
Ist die Fruchtblase schon geplatzt?
Jawohl. Spüren Sie schon die Hufe?
Der Bauer spürt keine Hufe.
Vermutlich liegt das Kalb
in einer schlechten Position.
Ich komme sofort.
Wenn trotz Wehen
die Geburt nicht beginnt
und das Kalb nicht rauskommt,
muss man sofort reagieren.
Es droht nicht nur eine Totgeburt,
auch die Mutter könnte sterben.
Die Zeit drängt.
Die Fahrt nach Fahy an der franzö-
sischen Grenze dauert gut 15 Min.
Auf seinem Hof züchtet Christophe
die Kuhrasse Gasconne,
zu der auch Bonny gehört.
Aber sie ist anders als die anderen.
Sie hat einen sehr guten,
folgsamen Charakter.
Sie eigentlich die perfekte Kuh.
Schon am Morgen sah ich,
dass sie kalben wollte.
Ich schaute jede Stunde nach,
aber es passierte nichts.
Sie presste, aber das Kalb bewegte
sich nicht, da es falsch liegt.
Christophe ist nervös.
Der 35-Jährige ist noch nicht lange
der Besitzer des Hofes.
Weil er wenig Erfahrung hat,
setzt er alles auf Eléonore
und ihre Assistentin Camille.
* Dramatische Musik *
Mach, mach, mach, mach, mach!
Als Erstes kontrolliert Eléonore die
Lage des Kalbes in der Gebärmutter.
Sie schaut schon, schon gut.
Ist gut so?
Und dann ein überraschender Besuch.
Was ist hier los?
Es ist Christophes Schwiegervater.
Sie hätte schon
um 10 Uhr kalben sollen.
Ich hätte schon um 10 Uhr angerufen,
war aber gerade abwesend.
Man muss sie auch
selber machen lassen.
Vor Kurzem übergab Nicolas
seinem Schwiegersohn den Hof.
Aber er ist trotzdem
immer in der Nähe.
Wie liegt sie drin?
- Ich finde keinen Hintern.
Hast du den Schwanz?
- Ja.
Keine Füsse.
- Das dachte ich mir eben.
Normalerweise
kommt ein Kalb kopfvoran
und mit beiden Vorläufen voraus
auf die Welt.
Diese Position wäre ideal.
Dieses Kalb aber liegt verkehrt
und hat die Beine angewinkelt.
So kann es rein anatomisch
gar nicht funktionieren.
Ich komme nicht an die Läufe ran.
Sitzt es?
- Ja, es sitzt.
Dann muss man es umdrehen.
Nein, nein, es liegt auf dem Bauch,
aber ich kann
die Beine nicht ausstrecken.
Ah, die Läufe.
Sie sind nicht normal gebogen.
Ich spüre nicht mal die Klauen.
Das Problem war,
dass das Kalb weit oben lag.
Ich konnte die Klauen nicht greifen,
meine Arme sind zu kurz.
Eléonore versucht, den Schwiegervater
von sich zu überzeugen.
Veterinär ist ein Männerberuf.
Dafür braucht es kräftige Arme.
Sie hat nicht genügend Kraft.
Sie ist nett,
aber das ist ein harter Beruf.
Da braucht man viel Kraft.
Das weiss ich aus Erfahrung.
Die einzige Lösung, die mir
noch bleibt, ist aufzuschneiden.
Wir versuchen es nicht mehr länger.
Wir schneiden sie auf.
Kaiserschnitt?
- Mhm.
Jesses Gott!
Ein harter Schlag für Christophe.
Man befürchtet immer das Schlimmste.
Ein Kaiserschnitt
ist ein grosser Eingriff.
Es ist nicht einfach.
* Melancholische Musik *
Aber Eléonore
hat noch ein ganz anderes Problem.
Ich bin nicht sicher,
ob es überhaupt noch lebt.
Na ja, wir müssen es holen.
Aber ein Kaiserschnitt
bei einem toten Kalb ...
Eléonore versucht, ruhig zu bleiben.
Aber ein Kaiserschnitt
ganz ohne Hilfe ist neu für sie.
Es macht keinen Sinn,
einen Alleingang zu wagen.
Sie braucht Hilfe.
Erschwerend ist, dass Samstag ist
und Eléonores Chefs
nicht erreichbar sind.
Camille ruft
einem pensionierten Tierarzt an.
Ja, wir sind hier.
Merci.
In der Zwischenzeit bereitet Eléonore
alles für den Kaiserschnitt vor.
Aber bei ihrer Rückkehr erfährt sie,
dass sich Christophe auf Druck des
Schwiegervaters umentschieden hat.
Am besten tun wir sie ab.
- Wie?
Das müssen Sie entscheiden.
Wir sind dafür nicht ausgerüstet.
Ohne Füsse macht es keinen Sinn.
Zwischen Christophe und seinem
Schwiegervater steigt die Spannung.
Es ist tot, nicht?
- Ich glaube, ja.
Ausser der Arzt
kann die Beine strecken.
Aber das bezweifle ich.
Wir haben fast keinen Platz.
Wenn nur ein Lauf gebogen wäre,
dann vielleicht.
Normalerweise
diskutieren wir nicht lange.
Mein Problem ist:
Das Kalb ist sicher tot.
Deshalb habe ich Mühe,
einen Kaiserschnitt zu machen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Schade, sehr schade.
Ein schwieriger Entscheid
für Christophe:
Kaiserschnitt oder Schlachthof?
Man muss etwas machen.
Das Kalb ist tot.
Ein Kaiserschnitt kostet 600-700 Fr.
Finanziell
lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht.
Sicher nicht ohne Kalb.
Eine Ammenkuh ohne Kalb
ist nicht interessant.
Die beste Lösung ist, sie abzutun.
Es ist entschieden:
kein Kaiserschnitt.
Entweder kann man das Kalb
auf natürlichem Weg holen
oder Bonny endet auf dem Schlachthof.
Eléonore gibt noch nicht auf.
Bald kommt Dr. Bonnemain.
Er hat mehr Erfahrung
und kann Bonny vielleicht retten.
Im Tierspital in Bern
geht es hektisch zu und her.
Hund Falco, der von einem Lieferwagen
mitgeschleift wurde,
steht immer noch unter Morphium.
Okay, dann ist es so.
William bereitet die Operation vor.
Insgesamt sind etwa zehn Leute dabei.
Ein solcher Eingriff ist ein Novum.
Wir haben drei Notfälle.
Der schwer verletzte Falco
wird in den Operationstrakt gebracht.
Er muss an den Pfoten
und am Brustkorb operiert werden.
Inzwischen spricht das ganze Spital
über ihn.
Auto mit Hund -
das nimmt nie ein gutes Ende.
Auto mit Hund - da verlierst du.
Das OP-Team versucht alles,
um Falco seinem Besitzer
gesund und munter zurückzugeben.
Er ist sehr sozial
und liebt Menschen.
Er hat seinen eigenen Kopf.
Ich bin ledig, habe keine Kinder -
er ist mein Begleiter.
Ich schaue immer sofort nach ihm,
wenn ich ihn mal nicht höre.
Eine ganze Woche ohne ihn
ist ungewohnt.
Neun Personen sind da, um Falcos
Wunden zu desinfizieren und zu nähen.
Sogar für geübte Augen
sind die offenen Wunden zu viel.
Es ist ein heikler
und riskanter Eingriff.
Die momentan grösste Gefahr ist,
dass neue Bakterien
eingeschleppt werden
und sich die Verletzungen
verschlimmern.
Das wollen wir vermeiden.
Der Eingriff dauert ganze 3 Std.
Dieses Herz soll Falco
ein wenig Mut machen.
Den Chirurgen ist bewusst,
dass die Wunden in den nächsten
24 Std. noch mehr schmerzen werden.
Der erste Tag
ist nicht der schlimmste.
Am zweiten Tag wird es schlimmer.
Die Haut um die Wunden
könnte absterben.
Und dann haben wir Wunden,
die noch grösser sind.
Zum Glück geben die Röntgenbilder
wieder etwas Hoffnung.
Wenigstens ist bei Falco
nichts gebrochen.
Aber nach dem Aufwachen
hat er unerträgliche Schmerzen.
* Jaulen, Winseln *
Man muss ihn gleich wieder betäuben.
Im Moment ist die Schmerzbehandlung
das Wichtigste.
Falco kommt wieder
auf die Intensivstation,
wo er Tag und Nacht überwacht wird.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
In Rolle kommt ein grosser,
scheuer Hund zu Gwennaëlle: Apache.
Guten Tag. Gwennaëlle Menoud.
Freut mich.
Seit ein paar Tagen
geht's ihm nicht mehr so gut.
Assunta, Romane und Louane
machen sich Sorgen.
Wir wiegen ihn erst mal.
Apache, komm.
* Schnalzen *
Apache.
Mein Mann und ich sind Hundetrainer.
Apache ist für uns
besonders wichtig. Das ist klar.
Wenn wir ihm
irgendwie helfen können,
dann spielen die Kosten keine Rolle.
Er ist unser Liebling.
Was ist denn mit Apache?
Er hinkt mit dem rechten Vorderlauf.
- Okay.
Anfangs humpelte er nur kurz
nach dem Aufstehen,
doch dann wurde es stets schlimmer.
Es kann natürlich passieren,
dass ein Hund humpelt,
wenn die Muskeln noch kalt sind.
Irgendetwas bereitet ihm Schmerzen.
Dagegen möchten wir
etwas unternehmen.
Kam es von einem Tag
auf den anderen?
Es kam schleichend, ich habe
es nicht auf Anhieb realisiert.
Manchmal bleibt er stehen
und hebt sein Bein.
Nach einigen Schritten
geht es dann wieder.
Okay, klar.
Etwas stört ihn,
vielleicht hat er Schmerzen.
Wie Menschen ertragen auch Tiere
Schmerzen unterschiedlich gut.
Ich würde gerne sehen,
wir er draussen geht.
Kein Problem.
Gwennaëlle möchte es genau wissen
und fragt,
ob Apache draussen
ein paar Schritten machen könnte.
Aber um diese Zeit
sind Apaches Muskeln warm.
Er zeigt keine Anzeichen
von Schmerzen.
Es scheint ihn
auch nichts zu behindern.
Es fällt einem nicht sofort auf,
dass er hinkt.
Heute war er schon spazieren
und geht ganz normal.
Humpelte er schon früher
oder hatte er sonst schon was?
Nicht, seit er bei uns ist.
Aber er hat
eine schwierige Vergangenheit.
Woher kommt er?
- Aus Spanien.
Der Hund wurde ausgesetzt.
Vor uns war er
bei einer anderen Familie.
Das hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Er ist völlig traumatisiert.
Unberührbar.
Der Penis ist vorne beschädigt.
Wir wissen nicht, was passiert ist.
Die Zunge ist wie zerfleddert.
Durftest du ihn anfangs streicheln?
- Non.
Was hast du stattdessen getan?
- Ihn in Ruhe gelassen.
Apaches Vergangenheit
gibt Gwennaëlle zu denken.
Während des Studiums absolvierte sie
in Spanien ein Praktikum.
Ich arbeitete zwei Wochen
in einem Tierheim in Sevilla.
Mit 550 Hunden.
Es läuft dort anders,
es ist eine andere Medizin.
Man sieht Dinge, die man bei uns
nicht oder höchst selten sieht.
Ich sah Hunde
mit Verletzungen durch Zigaretten.
Das hat mich schockiert.
Oder auch Schrotreste in den Pfoten.
Sie wurden nach der Jagd
einfach ausgesetzt.
Obwohl normalerweise ängstlich,
reagiert der Hund praktisch nicht,
wenn Gwennaëlle an seinen Beinen
rumdrückt und ihm sicher wehtut.
Was steckt hinter dieser Apathie?
Jahrelange Misshandlungen?
Ich vermute stark,
dass es eine Arthrose ist.
Sie hat den Hund bekommen,
als dieser vier war.
Sie weiss nicht,
was er durchgemacht hat.
Vielleicht
wurde er schlecht behandelt
oder ein Beinbruch
ist schlecht verheilt
und er hat jetzt
an dieser Stelle eine Arthrose.
Aber eine Arthrose
an nur einem Bein ist seltsam.
Leider kann er uns nicht erzählen,
was passiert ist.
Ich schlage eine
entzündungshemmende Behandlung vor.
Mit dieser Behandlung kann Gwennaëlle
noch etwas Zeit gewinnen,
um zu schauen,
wie sich Apaches Bein entwickelt.
Wird es nicht besser,
muss man röntgen.
Ich würde manchmal am liebsten
alle Untersuchungen durchführen.
Aber es ist auch
eine Frage des Geldes.
Deshalb ist es
bei weniger schlimmen Fällen besser,
wenn man etwas zuwartet,
denn manchmal
erholt sich der Körper von allein.
Na, mein Grosser.
Dir macht das gar nicht so viel aus.
Ich bereite kurz alles vor.
Ein Arthrose ist zwar lästig,
aber man kann sie behandeln,
mit entzündungshemmenden Mitteln
oder anderen Methoden.
Vielleicht gehen wir noch
zu einem Osteopathen.
Apache und seine Familie
gehen beruhigt wieder nach Hause.
* Blöken *
* Fröhliche Musik *
Unterdessen ist Eléonore
voll im Stress.
Sie versucht immer wieder,
das Kalb aus Bonnys Bauch zu ziehen.
Einen letzten Versuch soll
Besitzer Christophe selbst wagen.
Denn bei jeder Wehe wird ihr Arm
von der Gebärmutter zusammengedrückt.
Wir geben ihr jetzt Alkohol.
Eléonore schlägt vor,
der Kuh Wein zu geben,
damit sie aufhört zu pressen.
Ich komme nicht rein.
- Achtung, ich habe ein Gelenk.
Ich weiss, meine Liebe, es schmerzt.
Mit dem Wein
sollten die Wehen schwächer werden.
Vielleicht können sie so
das Kalb doch noch entbinden.
Christophes Frau
verabreicht Bonny Wein,
während Christophe noch einmal
versucht, seine Kuh zu retten.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich.
Es ist eingeklemmt.
Jetzt nach oben, oder?
Mit der Hand packen
und in Ihre Richtung ziehen.
Ich muss die Klaue packen ...
- Mhm.
Es fehlt nicht viel.
Ich habe es fast.
Ich versuchte, es zu drehen.
Es hat nicht viel gefehlt.
Ich bin fast bis zur Klaue gekommen,
aber mir fehlt die Erfahrung.
Kommen Sie mit den Fingern ran?
- Fast.
Ich habe es wirklich fast.
Es fehlt fast nichts mehr.
Ich habe es fast.
Es fehlt nicht mehr viel.
Hör auf zu pressen!
Christophe tut alles, was er kann,
um seine Kuh zu retten.
Guten Tag, Dr. Bonnemain.
Zum Glück kommt jetzt
doch noch Verstärkung:
Dr. Bonnemain ist da.
Wir versuchten,
die Läufe zu strecken.
Sie sind beide total angewinkelt.
Dr. Bonnemain
ist seit vier Jahren pensioniert,
aber noch genauso geschickt
wie früher.
Ah, okay. Es sitzt.
Haben Sie ihr schon was gegeben,
um die Gebärmutter zu entspannen?
Nein.
So hätten wir mehr Platz,
um zu arbeiten.
Ein Muskelrelaxans?
- Ja.
Eléonore spritzt Bonny
ein Muskelentspannungsmittel.
Bei dieser Aktion hat sich Eléonore
an der Hand verletzt
und muss jetzt untätig zuschauen.
Ich bereue es nicht,
eine Frau zu sein.
Trotzdem fühlt man sich manchmal
ohnmächtig und macht sich Vorwürfe.
Kein Ahnung, warum.
Jeder ist, wie er ist.
Aber das Gefühl von Hilflosigkeit
ärgert mich.
Es hat keinen Platz,
um sich zu drehen.
Und plötzlich gelingt es
Dr. Bonnemain doch noch,
zwei Läufe des toten Kalbs
herauszuziehen.
Haben Sie beide?
Es ist immer schwierig,
wenn es mit dem Becken voraus kommt.
Der Kopf sollte wie ein Keil
im Geburtskanal liegen.
Jetzt steckt der Körper
wie ein Block im Kanal.
Das Fell
liegt auch noch gegen den Strich.
Es ist wirklich schwierig.
In diesem Moment dachten wir,
alles wäre gut,
wir müssten das Kalb
nur noch rausziehen.
Wir waren froh,
dass kein Kaiserschnitt nötig war.
Habe Sie gesehen,
wie lange er brauchte?
Wäre er heute Morgen gekommen,
wäre jetzt alles gut.
Aber so ist es nun.
Ich bereue nichts.
Die Spannung lässt nach: Sogar
der Schwiegervater wird freundlicher.
Sie sind halt zu kurz.
Haben Sie keine Verlängerung dabei?
- Schön wär's, das wäre praktisch.
Das sollte es eigentlich geben.
- Stimmt.
Sie ist sympathisch, sehr sogar.
Sie muss aber noch viel lernen.
Das ist bei allem so.
Das kommt schon noch.
Aber bei der Geburt eines Kalbes,
da braucht es einfach ...
... starke Arme und viel Kraft.
Das kann ich nicht ändern.
Ich weiss, niemand kann zaubern.
Als letzter Schritt
muss das tote Kalb
mit der Abkalbehilfe
rausgeholt werden.
Warten Sie einen Moment.
- Brauchen Sie noch mehr Gel?
Jetzt kommt der Schenkel.
Noch ein wenig ...
Bonny lässt sich völlig erschöpft
zu Boden fallen.
Das Kalb muss dringend raus.
Ja.
* Muhen *
Eléonore wird langsam unruhig.
Es dauert schon viel zu lange.
Und jetzt lösen.
Jetzt nach unten damit.
Klemmt es? Ist es blockiert?
Es ist zu gross.
- Es ist zu gross. Zu gross.
Leider hat es nicht geklappt.
Ich konnte es auch
mit dem Gerät nicht holen.
Ich hatte diese Komplikation
nicht erwartet.
Ich dachte, das Strecken der Läufe
wäre das Problem,
wenn wir sie greifen könnten,
würde es rauskommen.
Aber ... es wollte nicht kommen.
Für Bonny
gibt es noch zwei Möglichkeiten:
ein Kaiserschnitt
oder das Schlachthaus.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ist gut.
Wir Tierärzte möchten natürlich
mit einem Kaiserschnitt
das Leben der Kuh retten - aber
das können wir nicht entscheiden.
So. Jetzt haben wir
noch zwei Möglichkeiten.
Christophe und seine Frau stehen
vor einer schweren Entscheidung.
Ein Kaiserschnitt ist teuer
und es ist ungewiss,
ob Bonny dann nochmals kalben kann.
Eine Kuh ohne Kalb
ist nicht rentabel.
Es ist hart.
Das Tier abtun
oder ein Kaiserschnitt -
das ist keine einfach Entscheidung.
Wir haben nicht viel Zeit,
zu überlegen.
Es ist ein liebes Tier und ich hätte
lieber einen Kaiserschnitt gemacht.
Aber mein Schwiegervater
war dagegen.
Er hat auf dem Hof
immer noch das Sagen.
Ich höre gerne auf ihn,
er hat mehr Erfahrung, aber eben ...
Was sollen wir auch anderes tun?
Abtun und fertig.
Wir haben auch Grosskinder.
Hier geht es nicht um Kinder.
Es ist nur eine Kuh -
das ist nicht so schlimm.
Es ist ein Verlust,
aber das gehört zum Beruf.
Es läuft nicht
immer alles nach Wunsch.
Jedes Lebewesen kann krank werden.
Wir haben 150 Tiere.
Da muss man nicht lange überlegen.
Der Fall ist klar:
Christophe muss Bonny
zum Metzger bringen,
auch wenn es ihm sehr schwerfällt.
Es tut mir sehr weh,
mit ihr zum Metzger zu gehen.
Bei einer anderen Kuh
hätte es mir weniger wehgetan.
Aber Bonny
war wirklich ein gutes Tier.
Eléonore ist auf dem Nachhauseweg.
Die junge Tierärztin aus der Stadt
muss noch lernen,
dass die Welt der Bauern rau ist.
Das frustriert mich
am meisten bei diesem Job.
Man darf nie vergessen,
dass es bei Nutztieren immer
einen finanziellen Aspekt gibt.
Auch wenn die Bauern sie mögen,
es ist ihre Einnahmequelle.
Wir Veterinäre vergessen das oft,
v.a. wenn man jung ist,
frisch von der Universität kommt
und etwas idealistisch ist.
Aber die Realität ist eine andere.
Es ist frustrierend, enttäuschend
und sogar traurig,
denn ich bin sicher,
es hätte anders laufen können.
Auch Gwennaëlle
von der Tierpraxis in Rolle
hat einen langen Tag hinter sich.
Ob eine Bagatelle
oder ein grosser Schreck -
alle Tiere konnten am Schluss
wieder nach Hause.
He ...
Hoi.
- Hoi, Sämi.
Ach, du ...
Fertig gechippt.
Ich habe ihn gechippt.
Ade. Ade miteinander.
Jetzt warte mal.
Zuerst pinkelst du,
dann gibt es etwas zu essen.
Nur das Marderbaby ist noch da.
Weil es ein Wildtier ist,
darf man es nicht adoptieren.
Gwennaëlle möchte es in einem Zoo
oder bei einem Wildhüter
unterbringen.
Guten Tag.
Hier ist Gwennaëlle Menoud.
Ich rufe an,
weil unsere Tierpraxis am Wochenende
einen jungen Marder bekommen hat,
dessen Augen noch geschlossen sind.
Wir haben ihn beobachtet
und gefüttert.
Und jetzt ...
... wollen wir wissen, wohin wir ihn
zur Pflege geben können.
Ah, das tun Sie nicht.
Die Augen sind noch geschlossen,
und es geht ihm gut.
Und wenn wir ihn
noch etwas behalten würden?
Aber ja ... Ich weiss.
Ist das erlaubt? Wir würden
ihn später wieder aussetzen.
Ja. Mhm.
Ja.
Natürlich nur so lange,
bis er überleben kann.
Es ist verboten,
Wildtiere zu halten.
Ich dachte an eine Unterbringung
in einem Heim.
Aber sie haben schon
genug Probleme mit Mardern.
Und mit geschlossenen Augen:
keine Chance.
Wir werden ihn einschläfern müssen.
Es ist verboten,
ihn bei uns zu behalten.
Dann tun wir halt,
was wir tun müssen.
Schade.
* Sanfte Musik *
In Bern treffen wir wieder auf Falco,
der von einem Lieferwagen
auf der Strasse nachgeschleift wurde.
Seit drei Monaten
lebt er in dieser Hundebox.
Aber heute
ist ein besonderer Tag für Falco,
der zum Liebling des Spitals
geworden ist.
Er ist super und nach all
den Monaten noch lieb zu uns,
obwohl wir ständig
an ihm herumdoktern
und ihn kontrollieren mussten.
Er war immer froh, uns zu sehen.
Auch für Yves ist es endlich so weit.
Guten Tag.
Ich komme meinen Hund abholen.
Falco geht wieder nach Hause.
Hey! Wer ist da?
Schau mal! Schau mal!
Salut, mein Süsser.
Salut.
Oh, wie geht es dir?
Wie geht es dir?
Wir gehen wieder nach Hause.
Hey! Hey! Gehen wir nach Hause?
Gehen wir nach Hause?
Also, komm!
* Heitere Musik *
So ...
Du siehst wieder viel besser aus.
Nicht?
Ja. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Es sieht recht gut aus.
Die Augen sind wach.
Er möchte herumtollen.
Nicht?
Es ist toll,
ihn wieder zurückzuholen.
Es macht einfach Freude,
ihn wiederzusehen.
Wie geht es deinen Pfoten?
Es ist ja noch alles dran
an deinen Pfoten.
Es ist alles nachgewachsen.
Ich weiss nicht, wie,
aber es ist noch alles dran.
Wie machen die Katzen? Miau!
Wo ist sie? Wo ist ...
Nach ein paar Wochen Reha
kann Falco wieder normal gehen.
Gehen wir nach Hause?
Also los, komm!
Nein, nein, nein.
Nicht runterspringen!
Yves erhält eine gesalzene Rechnung:
18'000 Fr. für den Spitalaufenthalt.
Er wollte seinen Hund
um jeden Preis retten
und hat dafür
seine Ersparnisse geopfert.
Die Versicherung
des Lieferwagenfahrers
übernimmt nur einen Teil davon.
Und jetzt noch die Vorschau auf die
nächste Folge von "Tierärztin 24/7":
Komm!
Eléonore im Jura hat grösste Mühe,
Juliettes Klauen zu behandeln.
Ja, ja, ich weiss,
dass dir das nicht passt.
Im Tierspital in Bern
probiert William alles,
um den an einem Virus
erkrankten Welpen Leo zu retten.
Man hat immer eine Chance.
Entweder geht es gut oder nicht.
Gwennaëlle muss Sissi operieren.
Dem Kaninchen
wurde ein Bein amputiert
und es hat die Klammer des Verbandes
weggeknabbert.
* Fröhliche Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020